hey you guys flickers of fear time once
again now i think if you guys are on our
patreon i think i might have announced
that on this particular saturday i was
actually going to review dario argento's
bird with the crystal plumage which i
will get to eventually i promise but
what ended up happening if you guys have
been watching the show and i've been
having trouble with my internet
connection
bird with a crystal plumage i actually
don't uh own on any physical medium so i
was going to watch it online but because
i've been having trouble getting online
because of the move and everything like
that i decided instead i was going to
push that back until later and i was
going to review a movie that i actually
had on physical medium so that's what i
decided to do so today we are going to
talk about
a sort of lesser-known lucho fulche film
that not a lot of people kind of talk
about but for some reason i have a lot
of a really lot of affection for i don't
know there's just something i really
like about it this is
1989's the house of clocks
now what ended up happening with this um
so this is kind of like one of his later
films and like i said it's one that not
a lot of people talk about probably
because it didn't really get much of a
theatrical release what ended up
happening was that
i guess italian horror cinema um in the
1980s was sort of going you know
downhill a little bit and it seemed like
a lot of the scary [ __ ] a lot of the
horror [ __ ] like moved to tv so it was
like a big a lot of big like italian
production companies were making um
horror for television and uh that's
apparently what this was going to be um
there was like a it was like a four it
wasn't a series necessarily but it was
like a series of four movies and it was
called houses of doom
and two of the movies were lucio
fulchi's movies and two of them were by
um umberto lindsay
umberto lenzies were i believe house of
lost souls and house of witchcraft and
the two lucio folgi ones were the house
of clocks and sweet house of horrors i
believe was the other one which actually
i don't think i've ever seen i've seen
most of his movies even like his lesser
known ones but uh but i have seen the
house of clocks and there's something i
actually kind of really dig about it
it's very funny to me
that
this was made for italian television i
don't know i'm pretty sure it aired i
think that this movie only got a
theatrical release maybe in japan and i
think it was like really hard to get
hold of in the united states for a while
like i got this dvd
like uh geez a long long time ago and i
can't even remember like what company
put this out but for a long time like in
the us it was kind of hard to get hold
of just because it was made for
television it didn't really have a wide
theatrical release uh anywhere on earth
really other than in japan as i
mentioned and i think that's kind of a
shame because even though
obviously like lucio folgi's later films
they were talking about like enigma
demonia stuff like that um i kind of
feel like they went downhill in quality
a little bit but i still think they're
definitely worth watching and i think
that the funny thing too is that i was
gonna say was that it's funny to me that
this was actually made for italian
television because i'm like wow italian
television could get away with a lot
more than american television could have
at the time this was like 1989 and uh
this is uh the house of clocks is like
actually pretty pretty gory not i don't
think it's quite as gory as like some of
his you know earlier [ __ ] like the you
know the beyond or city of the living
dead or whatever but it does have a
really lot of blood and a really lot of
uh gore in it and it's just like funny
that they would show that on television
i don't know that's just funny to me
because they would never show that on tv
here like back in 89 like regular ass tv
so what we have uh with this here
is there's this uh kind of isolated
country house
and it's you know it's like out in the
middle of nowhere and it's occupied by
this elderly couple victor and sarah
now
pretty much from the beginning of the
movie
you know like victor and sarah come
across as very like oh very you know
kind of his kindly grandfatherly
grandfatherly grandparently i guess type
people so they come across like that but
pretty much from the jump you know that
this is not really who they are because
even in the first few minutes of the
movie you see them doing like some
pretty [ __ ] up [ __ ] now one of the
first [ __ ] up things actually the
opening scene
is their maid or their housekeeper maria
and she sees she's kind of like creeping
through the house doing whatever she
does
and she sees like blood all over the
floor
and so she follows this trail down and
there's down in the basement or
something like that there's like a
chapel down in there and she opens the
chapel door and she sees
a man and a woman in like wedding
clothes and they're laying on these you
know
coffin not coffins really but just kind
of slabs really in this chapel and they
have like these big huge um like nails
like driven into their necks and they
look all rotten and gross and everything
and then maria is just kind of like what
the [ __ ] is going on here right because
like as you would
and uh then she still like works there
but she's still
she's acting a little weird toward the
old people now like
um you know what's with the dead people
i don't really get but she doesn't say
anything
now meanwhile you see like victor and
sarah going about their little day or
whatever um they call this the house of
clocks for good reason because victor
has been collecting clocks his whole
life and he talks to them and takes care
of them is that their children in fact
he refers to them as children many times
like he repairs one and he's like you
take care and he just like puts them
back in the thing so you can see that
they're a little like eccentric or
whatever
but as i said you can also see
that these kindly old people are not as
kindly as they would appear because
there's one scene in particular very
early on not you know right after you've
seen these dead people
in the chapel which at first you don't
really know like who did that to them
but then you go to a scene where victor
is like
uh at the table and he's like kind of
petting the cat or whatever and then he
looks over on the windowsill and he sees
this sweet little bird like on the
windowsill and he's like oh he crumbles
up some toast and like gives it to the
bird and then he takes like [ __ ] cane
and just goes back
and then he like throws it to the cat or
whatever so you know these kind of uh
you know aren't the coolest people ever
and then later on you find out like a
few minutes later you actually find out
that victor and sarah were the ones who
killed the people downstairs in the
wedding clothes these were their i think
it was their nephew and their nephew's
wife and you're led to believe at least
from victor and sarah's point of view
that the nephew and the wife came to
live in the house
but
were ungrateful like were ingrates all
they wanted was their money and you know
all this like i said i don't know what
really happened but that's what uh
victor and sarah that's how they
interpreted it so they decided that they
were gonna kill them and just put them
down in the in the chapel and just kind
of keep them down there for whatever
reason and uh i guess the nail in there
was supposed to keep them from coming
back to life or something like that i
don't know it's not entirely clear
so so there's that whole situation going
on now you like i said you find out that
these old people are kind of
bad
pretty early on in the film
so it's interesting then
to see this it's almost kind of giving
me like don't breathe kind of vibes
where it's just kind of like a like a
role reversal type movie but this came
out like a long time before that i'm
sure it's been done uh before that but
it's just every whenever i saw it don't
breathe i was like oh kind of like house
of clocks where you know the there where
these people come because there's these
sort of hoodlums they're not they don't
really look like hoodlums they just look
like regular ass
you know young people but it's uh two
guys and a girl and i guess tony and
diana are like boyfriend and girlfriend
and then there's like the third wheel
whose name is paul who's kind of a dick
so they're driving around and you can
tell their dicks like pretty much right
away because they stop at this
supermarket and like she
goes and distracts the shop owner with
like look i really want this kind of
underwear or whatever while the dudes
like kind of steal the dude blind right
like steal like [ __ ] pork rinds or
whatever they're stealing potato chips
mixed pickle i think he says what they
took but uh yeah so they're stealing a
bunch of stuff they're smoking pot and
uh and then they find this is kind of
[ __ ] up um they find a kitten
in their car which is i guess like
stowed away while they were in there
robbing the store
and paul decides hey i'm gonna put this
kitten in a plastic bag and then we'll
see how long it takes me to get out it's
like hey i'm giving you a fighting
chance okay i'm like all right kill that
dude so you already know these people
are shitty so apparently what happened
was that
tony or paul i can't remember
but one of them knew the daughter of the
gatekeeper at the house where victor and
sarah live and she's like hey there's
these you know decrepit old people
there's like there's nobody there except
them and their housekeeper
and um they have like all of this really
cool [ __ ] in their house like they're
really really rich they have like all
the silver and gold and there's all this
stuff and you can just like break in and
take them out and just like take all the
stuff so that's what they're planning to
do they're driving out to this remote
location and they're going to just break
into the house overpower the old people
and take all their [ __ ] you know so
that's kind of their plan for the day so
uh what they do is that diana she kind
of goes up to the door
and oh i should mention too before this
even happens not only do the old people
kill
the nephew and the wife
but once they figure out that maria
their housekeeper
has figured out that they killed them
then the old lady sarah decides she's
gonna kill maria too basically by
stabbing her right in the cooch with the
big
uh pole the big wooden pole and all the
intestines come out it's pretty it's
pretty gnarly so uh so yeah so they have
several murders on their hands and
they're just very
it's it's funny how um
just laissez-faire they are about it
she's just kind of like ah she just like
stabs her right through the [ __ ]
right right through there and then the
old age just like oh well that's taken
care of la la la you know it's just that
kind of [ __ ]
you know what i mean so it's like i
really like i really like evil old
people movies so it's like they don't
make enough of those but yeah so so
basically what ends up happening is that
the three hoodlums show up at the hou at
this remote house
and diana goes to the door and basically
gives the spiel about oh my car broke
down and you know i don't know where i
am i need to use your phone blah blah
blah
so the old guy is just kind of like oh
okay of course of course like you can
come in and use the phone and
he wants to like make her a plate for
dinner and everything like that and he's
being really nice uh to her
but meanwhile she's kind of like
unlocking windows and signaling to her
you know
to her [ __ ] degenerate friends like
to break in there and do it now what
ends up happening after that though
things go wildly awry not at all like
they planned
the two guys break into the house one of
them has a toy gun that they stole from
somewhere
so they're like threatening the old
people with it uh what they didn't know
though was that um there was also
another person on the ground whose name
is peter played by al cliver who's been
in a bunch of i believe he's a british
actor but he was in a bunch of um lucio
folgi's movies he was in zombie and some
other ones and uh so he plays the
groundskeeper who only has one eye for
some reason i'm not entirely sure i
don't think they ever i don't think they
ever explain like why he only has one
eye but he does so he basically like
pops in with a shotgun and like
intervenes
and there's a struggle
there's a big fight and everything like
that and then it ends up that one of the
guys gets the jump on peter knocks him
over peter's gun goes off and actually
ends up killing sarah
so at which point victor the old guy
gets really pissed off and he starts
like fighting with the other guy and
then the other like one of the other
hoodlums like picks up the gun and
shoots the old guy so now uh and then
they also shoot peter and kind of stuff
him in a closet it's interesting i
really like this part of the movie
because you're kind of led to believe
it's like look you know the old people
are bad because you've seen them kill
several people and an innocent little
bird like in the first like 10 minutes
of the movie so you already know they're
bad and you already know that the
hoodlums are bad obviously because
they've stolen a bunch of [ __ ] and they
killed a cat that they didn't even
really need to kill
and they're just like general douches
all around so it's kind of like you're
you're like oh this is interesting so
you kind of think that when the hoodlums
get to the house you think there's going
to be like a reversal like the old
people are going to kill them but then
the old people get killed like almost
immediately
so then you're like oh i wonder how this
[ __ ] is going to play out well that's
when [ __ ] starts going supernatural
remember how i said that victor had
collected clocks for a long time and
talked to them and basically treated
them like his children well
the clocks i guess are kind of in
cahoots with victor and sarah because
not too long after the uh after the old
people are killed all of the well all of
the clocks stop like the minute that the
old people are killed right and it's not
even just the clocks it's the [ __ ]
hourglass even the sand stops in the
hourglass you know what i'm saying so
this is some hardcore like time magical
[ __ ]
so the time stops and it's like the
the hoodlums are just kind of like ah
that's really weird but of course
they've just like oh well we were just
gonna break in here and steal some nice
silver and now we're responsible for a
triple murder so maybe
you know maybe we have other concerns
and uh they can't get out of the house
because
the hounds have been released quite
literally they have like a big pack of
dobermans and they're roaming around the
ground so the kids can't get out so
there's like okay well we're just gonna
have to like hole up here we'll kind of
stick the bodies in the bathtub or
whatever and then we'll hole up here
until the dogs get tired and wander off
and then we can leave and get the [ __ ]
out of here before anybody finds out
what we did
so that's essentially what they do now
the clocks stopping
is a prelude to
time actually starting to go
backwards so for the remainder of the
film
basically time starts going back but
it's interesting because
the
hoodlums are still in the house and
they're kind of like wandering being
like what the [ __ ] is going on and they
find like the
the bodies of the nephew and everybody
in the cellar and then as they start to
go around trying to get out of the house
they see that like some of the people
they've killed like peter the
groundskeeper like his body's not in the
closet where they put them anymore like
all the bloodstains have vanished from
off the floorboards
the table is set the way it was when
they first got there so time is
essentially reversing not for them but
for everybody else so all the people
that got killed are coming back to life
and it just kind of goes on like that so
basically the old people that you
thought were dead that got killed like
right away because of the time you know
the time distortions uh they actually
end up coming back and then there's kind
of like a big struggle
between them and the and the criminals
that broke into the house uh so that's
kind of how that whole thing goes now
it's interesting because there's just
something about this premise that i
really really like i not only like
because i really like movies about um
creepy old people and i really like
these kind of like creepy old remote
mansion type of things it's not like
it's like a country house it's not
really like a mansion and i also really
like the whole reversal thing whereas
and i like the thing where it's like
there's really no good guys it's kind of
like because the old people are bad and
also the criminals are bad obviously so
you're not really sure in a way you kind
of want the criminals to get it because
even though the old people are bad like
you know the criminals are kind of worse
and you know what the [ __ ] were they
even doing and they killed the cat and
you know i don't really have any
patience for that so you know that's
that's that whole issue but yeah so
there's just something about this that i
have like a lot of affection for i will
admit um it's been a while since i've
seen it i watched it again like um not
too long ago like just earlier today for
the review and it is like a lot slower
moving that i remembered but that
doesn't really bother me all that much
like there is like a really long time of
these criminals like wandering around in
this house being like oh my god like my
hand is injured and now it's not injured
anymore and where did all the blood
stains go and all the bodies are
disappearing and stuff like that but i
don't know there's just something
i really like about the atmosphere of it
and i really you know the gore it's it's
low budget because you know this was
made for tv it wasn't a theatrical movie
um so it looks a little bit
meh but it doesn't you know it's not
that bad
i mean you know it's it's decent by uh
italian standards uh and italian
standards for this time and actually
looks a lot better than some other
things that i saw around 1989 so i'm not
really complaining about that
interestingly though what ends up
happening
is that time goes backwards so much that
essentially because this i don't know
this is like a really weird like time
loop kind of film
because it's like so they they piece
basically like all the criminals like
get killed because everybody that got
killed like the old people in the
groundskeeper they come back and then
the criminals get killed but then the
time goes back so much
that
it seems like it goes back to before the
hoodlums even go to the house because
they're like parked outside it and then
diana wakes up and she's just like oh
man i just had the worst [ __ ] dream
and he's like yeah man so did we we had
like this crazy [ __ ] dream it's like
let's not go do this house now because
they have like a bad feeling about it
and then they're just kind of like
laughing about these crazy nightmares
that they had and they're kind of like
explaining
these dreams that they had to each other
like that were like scenes from the
movie it's like yeah this the maid came
back from the dead and like stabbed me
in the stomach with this big huge pole
which actually did happen so they're so
they're like comparing dreams they're
kind of like laughing about it they're
like yeah let's not do this house that's
probably like a bad omen or whatever but
then the cat that the guy put in the bag
at the beginning like
pops out of the bag and like starts
going all over the car and it makes them
crash and
they all get killed anyway so
it's really weird the way there's like
this whole like time distortion [ __ ]
going on and i like that the cat got
revenge uh and i i mean i like that that
kind of
played out again like at the end of the
movie because i was like yeah go kitty
get him even though i think the kitty
does die too i have to say because i had
forgotten about that i thought the cat
like jumped out of the bag and killed
everybody in the car because they
crashed and then i thought the cat
survived but i guess not because like in
the last shot where they're pulling back
from the car with all the blood and
everything like that there it looks like
there's like a little dead cat over in
the grass which is was kind of upsetting
because i said it would have been way
funnier if the cat would just jumped out
of the wreckage on this little tail
switched and been like that's right [ __ ]
that [ __ ] but you know what i mean
that's what i would have liked to see
anyway but yeah so like i said if you
like lucio folgi movies uh this isn't
you know obviously it's not one of his
uh best ones it's kind of like one
that he did later on in his life um you
know he did it for television so
obviously didn't have as much of the
leeway as much of the budget as some of
the other stuff but i definitely
definitely think it's still worth
watching as there's just something about
it especially the guy that plays the old
the old dude um the old dude victor that
dude there's something like really
creepy about that guy he's got like a
weird i don't know i think it's his eyes
he has like these weird like kind of
crazy eyes type glance and it's just
like him kind of
doddering through the house like and
just you know when he kills the bird and
just like the look on his face and stuff
like that he's like really really good
so this is kind of one i was reading uh
i have this book here that's uh called
beyond terror the films of lucio fulchi
and uh so i was reading the part about
house of clocks in there and it seems
like i mean the author of that didn't
really have too much patience for it
um saying that it was kind of uh lazy i
mean
luciofold she didn't write the
screenplay he did write the story but i
think the screenplay adaptation was
written by somebody else but um he was
responsible for the story anyway and i
think that you know the author of this
book kind of thought well you know
this stuff his stuff got kind of like
lazy later on he didn't really have any
internal logic behind his stuff which
seems like a strange uh thing to say if
you've seen some of his earlier classic
films like the beyond which also didn't
really have much internal logic that was
kind of one of his things but you know
it pointed out things like oh well you
know the the way the time distortion is
working is not consistent like
um you know diana gets her hand stabbed
by the old lady the likes hand stabbed
through and then it heals like a couple
minutes later meanwhile paul who gets
shot in the chest like his wounds don't
heal that fast but
when you're i don't know when you're
operating under something like
supernatural time distortion i think you
can kind of like give things a little
bit of leeway and i think the the the
thing about when they're when they wake
up at the end uh before it happened i'm
presuming and they're comparing
nightmares with one another and all
their nightmares are sort of different
because they each had a different
experience in the house so
i think that you could just kind of
explain that away you know yes it could
be lazy writing but you could also
explain it aways like well they each
were you know at times they were
separated so they each had different
experiences in the house so you know
what i mean so i so i don't think i
don't know it didn't bother me that much
i didn't really notice it really until i
actually read until i read about it in
that book and i was like oh yeah i guess
so but you know it didn't really matter
that much to me but yeah so like i said
if you um haven't seen any of lucio
folgi's lesser stuff like i said it's
it's not going to be as great as like
zombie or the beyond or
anything like that but it does have a
lot of gore in it it has like a really
cool like kind of a creepy uh atmosphere
i just really really like uh the whole
premise of like the time running
backwards like these these elderly
people that seem very sweet and like
your great like your sweet grandparents
on the outside but are really kind of
evil
and uh you know and somebody breaking in
the house and them just kind of like
coming at loggerheads and then like
supernatural [ __ ] going on i just think
that's a really cool premise and
honestly i think it was like pretty well
executed um you know no it's not as
great as some of his other movies but
as i said it's one of my favorites of
his uh later films and i'm just
surprised that it was made for tv and i
think more people should see it because
i actually kind of
i actually kind of really dig it um so
it's let me know if you've seen it and
if you have the same affection for it as
i do because i'm interested to know how
other people uh perceive this one
because i know it's one that i don't
hear a lot of even other lucho folgi
fans talking about but it's one that i
like a lot i also want to do
at some point i also want to do the
psychic uh because i really really like
that one that's one of his sort of
giallo movies you know i've always
wanted to do that one too because i feel
like that one's really underrated as
well uh just as this one is so yeah
lucio folgi's house of clocks from 1989
check it out or if you've already seen
it uh let me know what your opinion of
is it of it in the comments and i will
see you guys on the next flickers of
fear bye